hypergamy so i'm just curious um for the
ladies on the panel have you guys heard
of hypergamy
yes yes i have now you have
monkey points before today not before
today i googled it just for coming home
okay so hypergamy is the action of
marrying or forming a sexual
relationship with a person of a superior
sociological or educational background
so the idea is that when women date we
want to date up in some way whether it's
they make more money than us they're
more educated than us or
they're better looking than us and this
is just when you survey women on what
they want in a man
and what researchers have come to find
out is that 100 of women want 20 of men
and so the reason a lot of times girls
say things like men are trash men are
the problem that sort of thing men
always cheat is because we're all dating
the same ones
yeah
and some people think it's even smaller
some people say five percent but i just
say 20 on like the high end
wow yeah and is that overall yeah well
it's the way they find this out is
through dating app data
so there's only available the women that
want to date up there's only twenty
percent of yeah available so i'll give
you an example um
how many of you guys wanna do a guy over
six foot
no five ten
what's your height requirement go ahead
i don't think i have a height actually i
don't want to date anyone five five so
okay that's let's do five eleven five
eleven okay i'm barely five one so okay
you got the whole you got the whole
anything up here's a bonus so i'm five
six so i tend to want somebody around my
height or taller okay
yeah i mean i'm a fellow shorty so i've
never really had to think about it so
the reason i bring this up is because
most girls when i ask them height-wise
they want to date their height or taller
and so that's just a an example of how
women use hypergamy
so mike
yeah yeah you see right
interesting
so my question is
a common complaint that i hear from men
is that women have too high of standards
when
are standards too high and i want to go
around starting there
um
i don't agree with that statement okay
go ahead i just think a lot a lot of
dudes are weak and so
instead of rising to the competition
they'll rather tell women hey man you
should just want less but from what i
see in the dating game
the characteristics or the qualities
women want on
are things you can develop
you know some of the best seducers in
history maybe neil strauss who wrote the
game he's a bold 40 year old man and he
got the most tale of anyone in new york
so the idea that it's about being six
foot in a million that is completely
untrue and these guys know this because
they complain about chad and tyrone and
chad and tara is never like some rich
guy is it
you know so um yeah but those qualities
of being kind being charismatic being
sophisticated in some way being athletic
you guys can hit the gym you can learn
how to talk to women you can be more
patient
you know you could respect her more in
certain ways so i don't agree that the
standards are too high
okay go ahead
um
the standard's too high i think
i think women have
a lot of expectations
when it comes to men and i think
sometimes those expectations aren't
always realistic
i do think
that men obviously do think that women
think too highly of themselves sometimes
but
i think that's the them problem to be
fair i think they need to i think they
need to up their game in regards to
being a lot more
understanding when it comes to women
and yeah that's just that's my opinion
okay go ahead
um
yeah i'd say the same and women's
expectations more than standards
and
and
kind of loss of words
no yeah
i don't think women's standards are too
high i agree more or less with
everything um you said that
men have to kind of
come to an understanding of what
men have to be more i'd say more i'd say
women's expectations are more on an
emotional level
than a money level
for me anyway they want they want like a
guy that's emotionally available is that
yeah for me
it's
i'd rather someone that was emotionally
available than someone that had a lot of
money okay what about you i think it
kind of depends if you're looking at the
talk a little closer sorry it depends if
you're looking at the real world or
through dating apps because on dating
apps it's easy to say yeah i want x y
and z but actually when you meet people
naturally you'll find that a lot of that
kind of goes out the window and you're
happy as long as you just have that
connection or the basic fundamentals
with that individual which comes down to
like the emotional intelligence and
things like that as opposed to saying
okay what's your salary how tall are you
what do you do okay go ahead i would say
that there's a difference between being
selective and having high standards i
think that women and it's if you look at
dating app data it's very well
understood that the women are
they will they will swipe less freely
they'll be they'll think more about
their swiping and they'll probably swipe
write less often whereas men if you're
going to stereotype will just you know
they'll play the numbers game
um but i wouldn't say that's because
women are looking for a man of a certain
height and a certain income i think
they're looking for someone who they
click with more and there just seems to
be a phenomenon where men seem to play
the numbers game more okay what do you
think
i think a lot that was a lot to wrap him
alright firstly yeah
okay so
all right the eighty percent of men that
we're talking about
you have to understand
that they're completely invisible
we're talking about ram root from
chicken cottage
we're not you know what i'm trying to
say
right so when when we're starting we're
starting at a basis where you're already
oh this is tyrone he's already six foot
i already know what he does you don't
need to ask him what his career is you
already know he's so i want someone
that's nice is because you want someone
that's nice that already has the fits
the narrative that the person of what
you want
you're not going to be attracted to
someone that you're not attracted to or
doesn't fit your criteria and women in
the west criteria is very high
and they all have to they all seem to
have the same criteria they all want the
same type of guy even though they would
love to admit that they don't want the
same type of guy
maybe it doesn't work out with the right
type of guy and now you move on to
another guy that you you don't feel as
happy that you are with that guy
when really and truly you wish that guy
that you really want was like the guy
that you're with now
is more what happens when you say like
out on the road that you meet people no
people women have to settle and they do
settle when they hit the wall they
settle when they've been through too
much stress they settle when they need
money problems they settle when when
they when they that you know what this
guy's just on my case so much let me
just
all
right yeah that's when they settle but
they they're really trying to get that
main guy and if that main guy came when
they are in a relationship with that the
guy that they settled
hi pergami bro they're gone no i don't
know
what do you class as that main guy out
of curiosity
you know the guy
okay i'll give you i'll give you an
example okay
most girls that i know
even there's one guy that they just like
really deeply loved right and they loved
more than all of their other exes and
they could be dating the next guy or the
next guy or the next guy but if that ex
calls they're back
i disagree
i think
i think that comes with age okay i think
um obviously
i'm 40.
one sorry
i'm 41 and um
i don't go back
i go forward but am i ever going back in
my young i've gone back for sex
that's it
so i wouldn't ever look at that person
as to have a relationship with if i
haven't you know been seen anyone and
i want to have sex then i might go back
to that person or i did go back to that
person in the past but
yeah do you think it's your choice
of course it's my choice
you think a man wanting to have a
relationship with you is your choice
yeah i do
so what do you think will separate the
man that just wants to sleep with you
from the man that wants that
relationship with you
that's a very good question
but i don't know it's an individual
thing isn't it i mean
i can probably count on one hand the
amount of men who have just wanted to
sleep with me
so
yeah every girl wants to stop with you
yeah
no but i mean that have i mean i mean
we all know that when when a man meets a
woman it's initially you know attraction
isn't it like
obviously women have the same thing as
well it's not it's not just men by the
way that's not the same um well i can
look at a man and think oh i'd just love
to sleep with him but he's not i
wouldn't really want to be with him for
the rest of my life so we do have that
as well
yeah but do you get attached when it
happens i don't know
so do you think that's because you've
passed the stage where you can get
attached
no i've never been attached
you've never been attached through sex
no never never neither
never
you've never been in a long-term
relationship
but it wasn't because of sex and the sex
are you being has the sex kept us there
whipped i'm saying you've never grown to
love a man through sex
ever
no i don't think i have i've loved
someone's sex
because someone is good in bed no way
i'm not saying you'll stay only because
he's good in bed but that's typically
how women bond we release a hormone
during sex that men don't which is
oxytocin so basically like women fall in
love through orgasms as like as weird as
weird as that is but like yeah like
because we release a hormone that they
don't
but as somebody that so when i
have had a lot of long-term
relationships i'm like a relationship
person and i'll often wait for quite a
while before i have sex with the guy so
i want to date them first i want to get
to know what's about see if there's a
connection or anything like that and i
can also go through phases of not
sleeping with them because i think most
of the intimacy doesn't come through sex
it comes through spending time with that
person building a connection with that
person and making memories and things
i'm not i'm not saying that's the only
way you can bond with a guy i'm just
saying women bond through sex in a way
that men don't i think and and you could
you could think it whatever but i'm
saying like study after study will tell
you women bond in a way that men don't
maybe maybe i'm talking to four
exceptions i don't know so is that is
that why so men do not bond through sex
we do they
they do but not in the same way they
they get they release a hormone that
makes them territorial that's why like
some guys you know they'll sleep with a
girl and they'll move on and they'll
still be mad when the next guy hits
because they really still